JARED CROOKS: It was my first
time attending High Table.
And not knowing what to expect,
I thought it was
really fascinating because you
had a chance to mingle and
talk with people from
all over the campus.
My name is Jared
Aldwin Crooks.
I was an undergraduate
here last year.
In fact, I graduated in 2011
in the astrophysics
department.
And now I'm back in as
a graduate student.
We had this fascinating talk by
Professor Gmachl who talked
about her work through
electrical engineering.
And even though I'm doing policy
here at the Woodrow
Wilson School, I went because
High Table really gives you
that chance to just spread
your knowledge out and
collaborate with others and
make collaborations.
CLAIRE GMACHL: I'm
Claire Gmachl.
I'm a professor of electrical
engineering here at Princeton
University.
I really enjoyed the invitation
to the Princeton
graduate school High Table.
What impressed me most was the
breadth of students that came.
There were not just engineering
students or
science students, but students
across disciplines that came
and asked interesting
questions.
DAVID REDMAN: The graduate
school at Princeton University
is comprised of four major
academic divisions: the
humanities, the social
sciences, the natural
sciences, and the School of
Engineering and Applied Science.
We have, in addition, two other
professional schools,
Woodrow Wilson School of Public
and International
Affairs and the School
of Architecture.
JENNIFER HUYNH: My name
is Jennifer Huynh.
I'm a PhD student in
the Department of
Sociology at Princeton.
The environment here is very
collegial rather than
competitive.
Students have access to multiple
departments to take
courses in.
So, even though I'm a student
in the sociology department,
I've taken courses in political
science, economics,
the Woodrow Wilson School
of Public Policy.
So, there's this wonderful
cross-fertilization of ideas.
Professors and faculty are very
open to discussing with
you your academic interests.
NICOLE SHELTON: I think just in
terms of general research,
I always tell my students
to think big.
This is an opportunity for you
to explore whatever it is that
you want to do.
And Princeton is a great place
for you to do that.
And so, I encourage them
to shoot for the stars.
ROBERT KASTER: What to tell
you about Princeton?
It is for people in my field,
for people in the humanities,
the best working environment
I have ever experienced in
higher education.
It is supportive.
It is well-endowed
with resources.
And it attracts people who love
what they're doing, who
in terms of the faculty
love to teach.
No one comes to Princeton to
teach in the humanities who
does not enjoy having contact
with students.
And that, I think, is the single
strongest aspect of
having your education
at Princeton.
ANNE-MARIE SLAUGHTER: One of
the things I love about
Princeton is the combination of
a university that has been
here for hundreds of years
with state-of-the-art
technology and education.
We have lots of traditions
that we're very proud of.
One of them, for instance, for
graduate students is High
Table at the graduate college
where faculty members like me
go and present and then
talk to students at
dinner, at High Table.
So, it's that combination of the
old and the new that gives
this place its special
character.
One of the most wonderful
traditions is really the
hooding ceremony.
It is possible for the dean to
hood every single student the
day before graduation.
So, there's a marvelous ceremony
with all the friends
and family in the audience where
each student in academic
gowns comes up to the stage,
their name is called out.
And as dean, I would put that
hood over that student's head
knowing that student and knowing
something about where
he or she had come from and
where they're going.
CLAIRE GMACHL: I think it's a
wonderful graduate school.
I was so impressed by the depth
of the questions and the
breadth of the questions
that the students
asked at the High Table.
I think it's a wonderful
reflection
of our student body.
JARED CROOKS: If a school
doesn't have the mentors that
you need, then come to
Princeton because
we have them all.
That's all I have to
say on that one.